I literally have solved I think a couple
thousand puzzles in the last month I've
been doing so many of those funny and it
shows because you basically guessed
every move in this game which is
something that I would not have even
come close to doing with you earlier I
would give you like this checkmate in
one puzzle maybe even like a like two
weeks ago but now I'm showing you the
entire game and asking you to guess all
sorts of different moves so give
yourself a little bit of credit hey John
but you know and the puzzles that you
solve trust me the speed with what
you're finding these tactics is I mean
it's not even close and just the speed
that you're playing with is actually
faster as well well thanks man it's all
because of a good teacher
there are you Jen you like nomemes and
you actually are like an extremely good
teacher
I appreciate that well you know what
they say good student good teacher so
you make my job easy I've never heard
anyone say that but I'm gonna assume
it's a real saying thanks man
I don't think it's real I think it's
[ __ ] just like most things I say it
sounded like that you made hook well I
mean I haven't framed on my wall but
thank you for insulting my wall yeah
shitty walls
[Music]
so I want to show you one of the most
famous games of the 19th century and
it's a game that that I think is first
of all just amazingly brilliant you'll
enjoy the tactics I think immensely and
it'll give us an opportunity to segue
from just me rehashing a couple of
principles that you adhere to to
broadening your understanding and
actually putting your understanding into
practice I think you now have the tools
to appreciate how Grand Master's play
chess which is something that I've kind
of been setting you up for so we didn't
do this earlier because you would have
looked at this game and said all right
big [ __ ] like okay this guy played this
game what do I learn from it now you can
actually benefit from it because you
have that foundation already built so
let me grab my piano paint back story
behind this game first one moments let
me just pull it up how does that sound
I mean again if you if you want to veto
that you're welcome to so inspired to me
man
all right I'm always up for the classic
narrowed its Keilor session yeah there
is definitely some backstory behind this
game this game was played in okay let me
first invite you to an analysis board no
I'm not gonna put a space chat just
invited you all right so most people
think that they know which game I'm
going to show you but they actually
don't this game was played in the year
1895 in a small English seaside town
called Hastings
which thanks for the bits up man which
basically is just like a tiny like bar
hopping pub town but as with all major
chess tournaments they usually held in
[ __ ] holes like the bigger the [ __ ]
of a town it is the more likely that a
very high-profile international chess
tournament solved there they're like I
won't tell it to the reasons for that
but you know
it just that just does exist that
relationship but anyways this tournament
was this basically the strongest
tournament ever held in the 20th
centuries held every year in this town
of Hastings and all of the top chess
players of the day converged on that
tiny town which by 19th century
standards was huge because the
logistical nightmare of that was as you
can understand events so this game was
played by a guy named Wilhelm steinitz
who at the time was the world chess
champion he was also the first official
world champion and his opponent and like
you cannot make these names up like I
feel like only chess players have these
names his opponent was a guy named Kurt
von Bartle Evan who's going yeah he
sounds like his name sounds a lot more
intimidating than Steinitz but he was
actually a lot worse at chess
when Steinitz and kurt von rönn Bartle
Evan was a bit of a how do you put it a
bit of a pressure cooker he had a bit of
a short fuse so there was a incident
that happened at the end of this game
that I'll guess you but let's get to the
game so Stein it's lad the white pieces
von bird of 11 has the black pieces so
you can paint yourself that picture
there are chain smoking cigarettes you
know leaning back in their chairs and
here they go
Stein is go c4 and the most popular
opening yeah that's it did you enjoy the
game Charlie please tell me like the
game I feel like I've learned a lot
already Daniel I mean here von Bartle
ebon saw the power of statuses move and
he simply put his game down I mean he
said I cannot take this guy's mastery
any further it's before Jesus Christ I'm
still recovering from or looking at this
move now you have to pay money to look
at every move in this game including
this one because of probably because of
its power so the bard 11 play c5 and up
until I would say the nineteen fifties
e5 was almost exclusively to move played
against T forth which point the Sicilian
defense which is c5 kind of replaced it
in popularity now c5 is the most popular
move at the top be 5 and the opening is
gonna be familiar to you it is the move
that you tend to play in this position
the Italian defence what
design its play c3 so that's the four
Knights the Talon is Bishop c4 oh oh oh
I'm sorry I'm sorry no problem
so Knight c3 is entirely possible but
Bishop c4 Bishop c5 let's play now you
in this position either develop your
neither you play the move t3 but I'm
going to introduce you to a slightly
different opening setup now when I make
this move on the board and you should be
familiar with its idea because you've
seen this move before c3 that's the move
steinitz place now could you decode the
idea of this move
yeah it doesn't want the knight on d4
number one and he's planning central
expansion with what move pretty
straightforward I mean it all revolves
around that square you just mentioned oh
I didn't have push-to-talk on I was
saying well no problem do people work
hard to be for exactly he wants to play
the move pawn to d4 this is actually the
main move in this position and we're
gonna go quite faster the first stage of
the game and we're gonna reach the fun
part because it's all theory Knight f6
by Vaughn Bartle Evan developing his
Knight stop me if any move is geological
or I'm going too fast
d4 by Steinitz occupying the center
attacking the bishop Vaughn Bardo Levin
takes the pawn and which way do you
think Stein is recaptures here he takes
with the pawn of course he could
preserve the integrity of the center now
obviously this move later became the
most popular move in this position it's
called back Apsara Fischer gambit and
it's like a positional Queen sacrifice
actually but that only happened in the
1990s why is that popular though it's a
queen for two pieces is that word it's
actually Queen for just kidding I'm
[ __ ] with you know this poem just
letters a queen it's big yeah I love
doing that I've actually made some okay
don't feel that because I've made some
like very strong players believe some
total [ __ ] just with you ever so I'm
gonna tear it of it that's genius
I actually pretty good at keeping a
straight face and like at chess camps
and stuff when I'm teaching though even
the highest groups all like sell some
total BS about some Queen sacrifice and
I'll pretend that this is like hot [ __ ]
nowadays and they all buy it you know
eat it up like a sponge trust you those
how could they possibly
what I was up to in my spirits I mean
especially whatever something with the
euro a but fortunately that is kept
under wraps so in any case he takes c4
by Stein in San Bernardo Levin gives the
check on b4 with a special which
Steinitz blocks with the most natural
developing move which move is that he
brings his Knight to D - that's a little
passive can he bring his knight out to a
more active square he brings it up to c3
bingo night see now it appears and we
won't dwell for too long on this because
this is still in the realm of opening
theory
it appears that sinus has blundered upon
what do I mean by that statement how
efore well the ephors not hanging but
are you sure about that because notice
the pin so in fact is hanging right
right right and this is a classic game
but again that is when you sack upon in
order to gain something in return such
as development so here block is kind of
forsake and his Queen side development
and instead he goes pawn grabbing and he
opens up an avenue to his King so just
from a conceptual standpoint is it makes
sense that a move like this is very
risky the pawns are core what you're
taking if you capture the pawn does
there's the riskiness of such a move
makes sense right so bard 11 did not
take the pawn and there's an own kind of
continuation this is still theory you
can take the pawn but the line go goes
on instead one Bart 11 plays d5 and
after etext e5 has he just himself now
blundered upon no well
yeah you can't defend that so how many
attackers does this pawn have Bowen has
Bishop on it and that's it okay and how
many defenders this is one half or I
mean from blacks perspective how many
bases are attacking him good night in
the Queen so can you take that pawn yep
absolutely
and I like that you didn't say the night
because the night has been so Knight
takes d5 right and this is a very maka s
construction because it's like the
bishop holding the world on its
shoulders if it fails in its
responsibility to pin the night you're
gonna lose your queen but it's like you
know pilots flying a plane you know like
the margin of error at the top becomes
smaller and smaller and smaller that's
why I'm teaching you openings to start
that are very solid it's hard to [ __ ] up
position like this you mix up the mood
or you take on d5 at the wrong moment
you see what I'm saying and you might
end up blundering your queen but at the
top this is like the theoretical line
fake stakes yeah yeah okay you were
gonna have something sorry I was gonna
say so if you did take that Queen like
let's say he did take bishop now he's
got his Queen at d5
don't you just push up the a pawn and
you're winning a bishop or the Queen if
he [ __ ] up well that's a good point but
he won't [ __ ] up he'll take the knight
with Czech removed the attacker of the
Queen ruin White's pawn structures
slightly and then he'll castle and then
he'll bring his own Bishop out to g4 and
he has a very commanding position
because he'll have a pin and he'll have
a nice Queen on d5 which is basically
unassailable by any cases so that would
not be a very advisable continuation and
Steinitz and such as castles and this is
another pawn sacrifice by the way and as
a tactical warm up for you this is again
not something I would have asked you
even a little bit earlier but if Bardo
weapon now takes the pawn on c3 Steinitz
has a very nice little tactic that wins
the pawn back and it uses I'm gonna give
you this one hints the undefended nature
of the bishop on c3 this is a to move
slash three move combination depending
on how you look at it
well the first thing I was looking at is
a way to win the bishop with a check but
I don't really see that the only thing I
see for that is pushing Queen e2 check
King falls back and you can't deliver a
second check in a position that can win
the bishop
right so you say that again after Queen
e2 check didn't either bloody wouldn't
block with the Queenie box with the
night or he moves his King but I
wouldn't know where to continue it from
here all right so your your binding up
against the right kind of problem which
is that it looks like you can't force
the king in the bishop so in those
situations you need to start thinking
about ways to bring the King on to a
square where it can then be forked to
the bishop
so that's a mechanism that you should be
looking at a cap so then we're taking
the pawn on f7 with the bishop to get
anything out we're putting him in check
yeah yeah exactly Queen b3 check and now
if you compare the safety of the Kings
it's clear that white is on top here
nice right so these types of things you
know I kind of look for automatically
whenever I see a piece that's number one
undefended and number two right in my
grille that's like Fort freaking fork
City right because the probability that
I'll be able to check that piece on one
of many squares increases and the
probability that I can use one of my
pieces to bring his King out is also
usually quite high so if we had these
two moves included and it was white to
move here could you do the same thing in
this position yeah just yeah you just
take on hh7 already and when you check
you check on no nevermind protected by
Queen well you're right so far no no no
so it's C - okay right c2 or d3 and then
you want the bishop back very good yeah
so that's why barred 11 doesn't take
that bond instead if he defends his
Knight with Bishop e6 Steinitz brings
out his bishop on c1 - its most active
square which is what that's going all
the way over there to g5 correct one
part 11 brings his own dish aback to
contest sinuses bishop is this making
sense so far we're getting to the cool
part I promise
steinitz initiates a humungous
monstrosity of a trade which takes off
basically all the modern pieces off the
board except
one night first he takes on d5 then he
takes on d5 again now he takes on these
seven and the question that becomes why
is he initiated all of this all to get a
boring position in which black is about
to castle and then black is gonna be in
excellent shape but the key word in that
statement is black is about to Castle if
you're looking at this position for from
White's perspective you have one
temporary advantage and you want to try
to make that advantage permanent what
advantage is that you have a diagonal
you can look at on a4 yes but what
broadly does that speak to you what
weakness does black currently have which
he hopes to solve on the next move he
has that night that is keeping the king
from check on like a rook e1 the night's
king tonight can be pinned the knight
can be pinned and that's exactly what
Stannis does and even more broadly the
king is on Castle right White's Genghis
Castle black Singh is on castles and
when you're evaluating positions you
know generally speaking the King's
safety has to be the number one factor
you're looking for who's King is safer
no it's absolutely White's King right
now right and when your opponent's king
is on castles and he's threatening to
castle you have to try to find various
creative techniques to prevent your
opponent's king from seeking shelter so
the rest of this game revolves around
White's desire to keep this king of the
center and eventually checkmate it and
blacks desire to basically shelter this
King at all costs that's where things
get super fun okay von bertalanffy six
he covers this each five square so that
white cannot jump out there with his
knight Steinitz continues to put
pressure on this night how how do you
attack this night one more time in one
of your pieces
not sure I can hear you it's not you
weren't saying anything oh yeah I think
they think sorry my headphones made the
sound that they're low on battery so I
did I didn't know if dad died thinking
is strictly forbidden yeah as long as
you need sorry I was just doing it you
only have your attacted that I can see
bringing into this is stacking so
bringing the Queen to e2 to also attack
the knight bingo that's exactly what you
want to do exact simple chess attacking
the knight forcing blacks queen to
finally leave its dominant post on d5
and assigning it to this defensive role
on t7 this is where it gets tough
because it appears that well what does
blacks plan in this position how is he
gonna extricate himself he's gonna go
King f7 he's gonna bring his rook to e8
and then he's kind of what's called
manually castle that's when you Castle
without actually castling because if you
Castle then that drops the knight on e7
right so you have to keep this Knight
defended bring the rook to e8 and then
get the King to g8 and if black achieves
all of that he is going to be completely
fine so White's time to do something is
very limited does that kind of make
sense yeah he has to look at a way to
stop f7 which is right and stylus is
able to kind of do that by playing rook
a to c1 and his idea is that he wants to
meet the move King f7 and this is where
it gets ya bard elements should have
still played king f7 but he made an
oversight Stein has had in mind a quote
unquote fork here for ting the King to
upon can you find this fork keeping in
mind why he might have played the mover
okay c1 this move should it should serve
as a hints
is it bringing the glue is what I was
thinking initially which is bringing the
Queen to c4 for the check make your
target okay that's exactly right
and what I was looking for yassuh Queen
c4 is right checking the Queen checking
to follow black and defend both at the
same time with white clever little
freaking bastard of a move well just
pushing that pod up right well you're in
check I mean I know that the great
charlie is above Jack but you know you
know you defend it with the Queen then
on d5 right protected by the knight as
well so this move is is is shitty for
several reasons first of all you don't
actually defend the pawn which is your
goals second of all you blunder your
Queen this 997 is overloaded it's
defending the Queen but it's also under
pressure so you can take the out miss
Knight you're taking it taking the legs
out out from the Queen right you're
close you see the right square sorry I
just
that was that was mean but this will
make you on the right move
yeah it's the ringing the night there
instead but exactly bringing the knight
55 and simultaneously defending see some
something that some people miss and you
know I'm sure you don't you're not one
of them but some people suggest oh they
think you can take on c7 oh but isn't
the knight pins remember that when you
move with the pinned piece you'll also
relinquish the pin so pins are in your
mind should be very impermanent things
they should be things that you exploit
as quickly and as efficiently as
possible so like sometimes in your games
you have to have that ticking time clock
in the back of your mind when you've
let's say pin his knight you have maybe
one or two moves to attack that pinned
piece before he had pins himself not
always but that's just something you
should bear in mind pins are extremely
temporary tactical things that you
should try to efficiently maximize the
potential of make sense
okay so bard 11 not being you know quite
as tactically advances Thainess plays
the move c6 which is redundant I think
he simply missed this move 95 against
King of 7 and here's Steinitz finds a
brilliant idea that rips open files and
squares for his pieces this idea follows
one of the most paradoxical principles
in I would say all of chess
I might have introduced this
you earlier it's a pretty advanced
principle which is that pawn
breakthroughs usually occur on the most
well protected square that your opponent
has that is just a almost frickin
universal rule in chess when you want to
break through with a pawn you do it on
the least likely square and which square
am I talking about right now and which
pawn break through am i talking about
right now well the most defended pawn on
the board right now is that c6 pawn so
you're just pushing up d4 to d5 bingo
it's defended thrice while the knight
isn't really defending it because it's
pinned because it's pinned but you can
kind of understand logically why this
principle operates because it's almost
like you know it's like that that thing
where you can pull out the bottom piece
of paper from a huge stack of books like
my English teacher used to do that when
collecting our homework you know what I
mean mm-hmm
so I think I have no frickin clue I'm
talking out of my ass as usual why that
works but for some reason it seems
similar to me like all of your
opponent's pieces are trained on one
square and then this is like a big f you
basically putting a piece on to that
square so all of his pieces are now like
unemployed so that kind of makes sense I
make it like that analogy but no I did
it
you've you've like removed the thing
that his pieces were meant to do now he
has to put up on on g5 because he can't
take this with his queen why not lose
the game you lose the game to checkmate
and this accomplishes two things for
what number one it opens a file which
file C and now you see how good Steines
was he anticipated this when playing
rook c1 he freakin calculated this and
that's why he put the rook they're
partially partially was to discourage
king f7 but partially was that he
thought the lion to file it open and
second of all you have now opened up a
beautiful square for the only white
piece that's currently not doing
anything which square and which piece
obviously am i referring to beautiful
central blockading square
are we talking about the night bringing
it over to d4 exactly and you might look
at this move and say what the hell it is
it accomplished first of all notice the
umbrella technique using the pawn of
your opponent as a shelter that is
actually a common little device black
would now like to get rid of this
frickin pond so at least the Queen would
make contact with that square so
sometimes your opponent's pawns are
actually good for you in that way now do
you see the threat that white now has
created if black makes an empty move you
have a classic distraction sacrifice
distraction tactic I should say using
this night on T for which tactic going
right to c6 very close but remember I
have a pawn on c6 so you have the right
idea in mind but it's not the right
square you do have to make contact with
the knight no but now it takes to the
pawn and then you take with the rook you
take with the Queen to take with the
Queen I imagine well he wouldn't I
imagine what if your opponent isn't an
idiot but very nice you actually
calculated it all the way but I would
now move my clicking away to f7 or
better yet you have now allowed me to
counsel my friend because now if you
take my knight joke's on frickin you who
left that rook on c6 what genius did
that oh right so you're very close
actually which move is a refinement on
that so in this he's threatening to
bring the knight over there to e6 then
red because then at a 6 he can cover it
good move good move you're threatening
of your winning but I specifically want
you
I didn't discourage you from finding a
similar idea to that one did I if I did
I'm sorry but you actually had the right
idea of of making contact with a 97 you
just have to do it from another angle is
it throat well it can't be putting the
Queen there right because I know it's
why most rate queens it's just are we
just attacking that Knight therefore f5
then yep and the ideas again I can't
take with my queen you've gotten so much
better at identifying squares that seem
to be defended but are not actually
defended you see what I'm saying
so a lot of people would throw this out
immediately Oh defended by the Queen but
the Queen is also overloaded its
defending the knight so on the next
movie just win a piece here you win the
night
okay that makes sense then so when barn
11 is not an idiot obviously he sees all
of this he goes king f7 and finally he
unpin himself but now this knight on d4
well and now why does not have five no
longer work simple question but you just
take what the knight right he's unpinned
himself but Stein is found finds a
second use for his night and you've
proposed this move before Knight to e6
okay and this 996 just is a boning box
throw you can just see how good it is
it's preparing moves like rook c7 and
you can see in what dire condition black
King is right yeah barn 11 swings has
rook over to c8 desperately trying to
stop White's rook from penetrating to c7
and this is exactly where Stein is
strikes on the other side of the board
notice the black has removed a defender
from the Kings side and that is now
exactly where Steinmetz presses in the
knife but he doesn't in a very smart way
remember what black's idea is black
wonsik to tuck his king away on g8 so
prevent him from doing that by making a
threat they see a lot of people in the
chat going for the tempting move but you
want to go for the correct one here so
what I initially saw was bringing the
Queen over to h5 put in check but he
wants to go to that square anyway and
that's the tempting move when you
refuted it correctly so but you're
thinking in the right direction of the
board it's not always about giving a
check though it's about the threat
perhaps I just don't see how to cut that
escape route off with the night because
he like if you do a move like bringing
the Knight to g5 and he takes with the
pawn right that's too much price to pay
though don't do just stop making a move
physically think of a move such that if
he plays King g8 he gets checkmated
think of it that way because stopping a
threat
I don't literally mean always physically
preventing him from going there I also
mean making a stronger threat that
forces him to divert his attention and
you can also arrive at this by asking
yourself now which piece has served its
duty and is now somewhat obsolete I mean
yeah so is it are we looking at that
rook
see one knot can't really do anything in
relationship with the kingside we need
to act very fast because if he plays
King g8 we have as I said only one tempo
here right we have one opportunity to
make something happen at this King as
soon as he tucks it away the party time
is over so you need to use your Queen
I'm gonna give you a hint it is a queen
move but it's not been h5 check oh Jesus
it's just bringing the Queen over to g4
and then threatened to go to g7 preach
exactly exactly and if he goes King g8
right we take on g7 but do you notice
any undefended pieces that black has in
sadly anything that's undefended maybe
x-rayed maybe Oh
H pawns undefended but we're x-raying
his queen as well with that Knight nice
and that's exactly what Steinitz
exploits on the next move bard 11
defends against checking with g6 and now
Steinitz exploits he checks with the
night and then he takes Queen right
exactly except part 11 being fricken
kurt von Bartolome he's not about to
give away his Quinn I mean he makes a
big dick move King he really is
defending his Queen and this is where
Steinitz lunch is one of the most famous
combinations of all time and what's that
it's notices here is the fact that not
only is the Queen semi undefended this
rook on ca do you see that it's being
x-rayed by two of White's pieces yeah so
all that stands in this rooks way all
that stands as its protection is this
flimsy little Queen on d7 except you
have just the way to distract this Queen
from its defensive post with what move
this is where science comes full circle
it's not as easy as I just paint it but
is it taking the night with the rook it
is very nice and if he takes with the
Queen you do what you take the rook with
the rook he takes back with the rogue
and you take with the Queen exactly and
the problem is if he takes with a king
then only the King is attached to the
Queen and you basically separate this
King from the Queen so basically here
you go rook to e1 check
King to d8 you give another check on e6
with the knight he has to go into the
path of the rook now some good practice
using the discovered check which I think
you sometimes tend to struggle with how
do you actually win this Queen on d7
using the discovered check where do you
put the knight so we need to do is stop
the King from being able to go to d6
right so he can't protect the Queen any
longer or we need to attack the queen
with the Knights
that's an alternate method right [ __ ]
yeah I thought too far so it's going to
c5 very good or you can taunt him by
going to f8 you could take your knight
here but you still take his queen but 95
is the best move because you actually
keep your knight on top of everything
then you take the Queen
but when Bart 11 actually finds a
brilliant defensive idea she goes King
f8 which looks like a total desperation
move until you notice the white also has
a crippling weakness in his position
what tactical feature is Vaughn bar 11
exploiting here
why can't science are squaring being go
the back rank and the back rank is a
very hard problem to solve on the fly it
just so happens that white also needs to
attend to the problems of his queen
thank you for the 15 bucks prefer nnedi
he has to attend to his Queen and his
rook you see how much [ __ ] is going on
with white yam now he has the back rank
to attend to but steinitz finds just the
way to do that he starts with a check on
f7 okay again if you take with the Queen
you take the win right careful I'm
waiting with out here back rank so what
are you actually going to take here you
need to take the rook again you take the
rook twice right but bard 11 moves his
King to g8 and here steinitz makes an
amazing fricking move try to find it
it's the same theme that his last move
was but it's a beautiful visually
visually beautiful move
it's not just pushing the rook up is it
it's not going rogue f8 and you're very
close now rook F a check is a very a
devious little move you wanted to take
with the rook right and then you can
take variant but he's gonna take with
the king and now we have the same
problem we're just missing the rook so
again we have a problem with a back rank
so what should you keep in mind here
first of all the fact that again don't
forget this Queen on d7 if it leaves
this square you'll be able to take you
his rook with your rock all right but we
but we can't do that yet because if we
take the Queen right now he takes our
range we lose so think of it this way
it's another distraction sacrifice which
attempts to distract this Queen from the
d7 square so you're getting close with
the move rook f8 but you're trying to
distract the wrong piece you need to try
to distract that Queen on d7 setting the
mousetrap for the Queen this is just
bringing the rook to e7 them but that's
not check yeah so we'd still lose right
it needs to be a check you're very close
but it needs to be a check and your
brain is like this move cannot be right
it looks too crazy it puts the rook and
under fire of like 18 pieces but that's
exactly what makes this game brilliant
so there's only two checks you can
deliver which is F 8 and then g7 which
one it is ok and what's the idea let's
unpack this first I can if he takes on
the Queen the reputation is familiar we
take the rook yeah but here's the
brilliance of this move if he takes with
the King a very important thing has
occurred the King has now moved from the
eighth rank to the seventh rank which
means we can now do what which we could
not do earlier due to the back rank
being weak
well what I initially saw was just
bringing the night for an e6 check which
could win the Queen but that's not gonna
right so you're not asking yourself how
does the position change do you need to
re-evaluate whether moves that used to
be impossible or now possible because
the position has changed in some way and
in fact it has the king has gone from G
A to G seventh which enables us to do
something we couldn't previously do you
you're like traumatized by this move so
you're not even considering it I told
you this move is impossible in your
brain you're like I can never take three
Queens for the rest of my life yeah all
right so it is just taking the Queen but
that's check now oh right oh right yep
yep yep okay I see what you mean so
that's why we we go to King to g7 it's
our check and that's one of the key
principles that I want to illustrate
with this game it's not usually shown
for the sake of in front of revealing
this principle but I still think it's
super important you see what I'm saying
now by reevaluating how the position has
changed whenever there is any sort of
dimension in the position there's a
hanging Queen that you cannot take for
whatever reason you need to keep asking
yourself can I take the Queen now can I
change the circumstances such that I can
take the Queen can I take the pin on the
next move because people kind of just
forget that the situation has changed
they get used to the position okay yeah
that makes sense
so Bart 11 goes to the corner because
that is the last remaining move in our
status plays yet another move that
exploits the same principle this one
you'll be able to find quite quickly
what does he do he just takes the pony
takes the fun in here Bart 11 snuffed
out his cigar and actually stormed out
of the playing hall without resigning
and without shaking hands absolutely
true story I told you he was known as a
bit of a tempestuous for his tempestuous
character and according to the official
gam annotations and I'm reading from
right now as Stein it and this you can
tell by the language when this was
written I should probably read it in
that old newsreel British accent you
know what I mean yeah we didn't
afterwards there is a mate in ten moves
which can only be averted by ruinous
loss of material and Winston Churchill
showed the
as photos King g8 and it looks like we
can keep playing ring-around-the-rosy
here forever but the reality is we've
taken that pawn on h7
so the situation has changed we give a
check on g7 he goes to a chain but
because we've taken this fun we have
opened up the H file and what peace can
we now put on that H file will you just
put that Queen in there you put that
Queen in there he has to take our rook
with a king and now we mounts the final
invasion against this King which check
do we deliver with our queen we're going
right to h7 bingo now we got a h8 we go
to g7 we hunt the king and its mate in
one of several ways King e8 is the most
resilient defense check on g8 we were
using the staircase method here how do
we complete the staircase we keep
approaching the king with our queen
use this night on g5 it defends a square
into which the Queen can now move - yeah
that's going to f7 bingo d8 continue
that staircase so now we're delivering a
check on FA brain go forcing Queenie in
now we have a checkmate in two moves
that is as brilliant as it is elegant in
what's fitting about this checkmate is
at the end of it all three remaining
pieces are rewarded for their staying
power because they all cooperate in
perfect Symphony to deliver the mate
each piece the knight the queen of the
rock are necessary components of this
checkmating idea made into white to play
okay does it start with taking the pawn
at f6 with the queen is checked because
then he can do blocked with his own
queen you need to know the piece it's
going Knight first then piece o almost
it's Knight f7 wait why not up six cuz
you still can't take it though if 96 he
goes King King up to d7 though and you
don't have that that final blow your
knight is now Hank oh right right right
okay so Knight f7 brings under control a
second square onto which you've been on
with the Queen which Square is that
that's going right to d6 and this is
checkmate right okay okay
so Bart 11 saw all of that you can see
that these guys were good he trusted
that Stein it's all of it so he actually
stormed out of
playing halt without finishing the game
and that is the games finest part 11
Hastings 1895 one of I would say
probably the most the 20 most famous
games of all time but it's actually not
shown us commonly anymore even though
it's one of my favorite games oh yes and
it just shows you a lot Josie how good
these people were even like a hundred
and whatever thirty years ago and it
shows you much much more foreign lady
urgency inherent in a lot of chess
positions like as soon as you see a
defect that your opponent has you need
to first of all pay attention to it
things like a non castle to King things
like a small defect in pawn structure an
undefended piece Steinitz basically
exploited all of it you know turning
from that on castled King to the
undefended Queen to the undefended rogue
to attacking weak pawns with his Queen
in his Knight notice by the way the
tandem the Queen and the knight remember
what I told you about it yeah strongest
combination this combination of pieces
known to man and Stein it's accused it
to check me to this mover okay to see
one involving every single piece in the
attack the more pieces are playing the
better yeah so now if you were in this
position how quickly would you recognize
this line coming out because this seems
like something that I can't even imagine
you would think of this deep right like
so it started where I think he probably
started the season so like a line that
deep was c1 to prepare to open that file
or where do you think like so would
start to recognize insofar as I can and
I can't tell you for sure because I
don't know and and it was very common at
that time to ham yourself up so sign
it's my very well upset and all I saw
the entire line until move for today
when I played the rook a c1 because I am
so but the reality was no he [ __ ] did
so I think when you play it when he
played rock a c1 he probably saw up
until 94 or he might he might have seen
up until 96 and then when he played
queen g4 my guess is he saw up until
rook takes c7 and he saw that he had at
least a draw right a draw because you
can keep checking the King ad nauseum
you know what I mean yeah so when you
find at least a draw you can go for that
line safe and the knowledge that if you
don't find a win then you're gonna make
the drop but that's where intuition
comes in sign
used his intuition to conclude that
essentially because he has so many
pieces in the attack like he must have
some sort of a win here he trusted his
own knowledge about the game of chess to
almost go into this line and then when
he reached this line that's where he saw
this idea of opening up the H file and
then driving the King sorry that's not
the right way this one and this one
driving the King to g7 are already at
this point he had calculated until the
end of the game so I think it occurred
in the three steps step one was this
rook c1 idea
step two was the sacrifice of the rook
on e7 and step three was the final
combination so it wasn't all at once I
think in other words makes sense so that
was like what what are your thoughts
about your first sort of full-on
classical game yeah I that's a lot of
very complex ideas a lot of thinking
really deep that I guess I'm not too
used to and then again another thing
that I recognized that I struggled with
even in this recap here knowing the
order of things knowing the right moves
but not when to make them right yes any
recognized when to make a move and when
not to so can you give one example of
what so I get a better context of
because I think I know what you mean by
that but could you find a moment in this
game where you would struggle deciding
on the order of things sorry not to put
you on the spot just so I get a better
sense so we can work on this maybe in
the future so recognizing that a six I
said e six far too early you'd play e
six when the king is on f7 I said play E
six when King was still on a e8
oh you mean 96 yeah
no but 94 he did play 96 actually almost
immediately afterward so like here he
did 1 94 96 but you did suggest that 96
might have been a threat whereas the
real threat was Knight f5 but that's not
really a big problem I can see why you
would be attracted by this move but the
way that you can actually think about
order in chess is that you want to make
the Moose that exploit the most
temporary advantage first so what does
that mean if your opponent is on castle
and he's threatening to castle and
you're choosing between a way to stop
him from castling or maybe a
to improve the position of one of your
pieces you know you got to do the thing
that's gonna escape you first so first
stop him from castling and then you can
work on improving your pieces so in your
mind you got to ask yourself okay what
is the most urgent priority in this
position we can work on that for sure I
could prepare some training positions I
realize that that is a hard thing to do
in chess I struggle with that as well
but from a general perspective I think
that's the mentality you should keep in
mind I know that's very general so well
that we're definitely going to work on
this yeah it sounds good to me and then
the other thing is chasing down the
checkmate seeing the checkmate
possibility but not knowing the order to
make the moves like I said taking the
pawn with the Queen which wouldn't have
been a checkmated would it give them an
extra escape square right oh you mean
here yeah so the thing is and this is
something you you learn also with
experience like when you're already in a
situation like this where you smell the
checkmate you smell that it's very very
near at hand you basically need to have
the line calculated until the end there
is a point at which you cannot rely on
your gut instinct to you know to
basically find the right move because if
you do rely on your gut instincts you're
gonna see like five different sensing
checks and all of them are equally
tempting so in a situation like this you
would need to calculate or at least try
to calculate at least several moves
ahead okay thank you fun bundle because
I feel like in your mind you took this
pawn with check and you thought this
move has got to be powerful because I'm
taking the pot with Chuck but you didn't
emphasize the question okay how can
black defend against this check then you
would see the move Queen e7 and at this
one it becomes clear that the King now
has several escape squares opened up and
also things working right and you can
think in terms of squares like think in
terms of which squares is the King have
like right now okay well it has this
square how do I craft the situation such
that he is the least number of escape
square as this move does come to mind
because it limits the king's escape only
to the move Queen e8 and now you just
the more you solve this is a line that
you'll just see I mean I don't have any
rational way to come up with this
sequence of two moves but by solving
checkmate puzzles you simply get better
at spotting the stuff instinctually I
would say
[Music]
you
[Music]